[Music]
welcome guys to the grandmasters choice
unfortunately it started a bit late but
nevertheless I hope you can provide some
content
so let's not waste time just get started
immediately
today's topic will be Italian game and I
chose this this other topic simply
because I thought the time game is very
popular nowadays
I played the quite often in 2019 this
year had ever gotten to play too many
games yet but internally I played quite
relatively often and I went to some show
some of my games with both colors with
violin black and let's learn what ideas
are there for for both colors so the
first game I went to shows my game
versus I mean Bassam from work team
championships were it was the first
round and it was it was important match
because it was my first time I played
for the United States in team
competition so it was a 45 9 f3 knight
c6 Bishop c4 Bishop c5 c3 Knight f6 D 3
D 6
short castle in general I'm there are
some lines of course with d5 the for
instance here is possible to play as
well short castle short castle t5 which
lead to simply different type of fight
personally I prefer to go for d6 at
least 2019 and earlier as well I used to
play employed only in the t6 quite
successfully so therefore just pay d6
castle a6 and right now there is choice
for for white white basically two main
moves a4 or B should be free this is one
plate but f4 is unbelie-- main move but
I don't want to dive into theoretical
debate about this opening I just more
like to show ideas what what are what
are the possibilities for both colors
here because with theory in like you
know in one in like you know one lecture
online I can basically include all the
ideas that are there basically program
masters is with computers engines teams
of people work on this opening and
impossible to just want a one lecture
include everything so I will try to
avoid looking into specific lines just
so many lines many ideas and this my
gold is the call this lecture a for it
is the similar popular move and here for
instance a very popular line short short
Castle Bishop g5 h6 Bishop h4 g5 Bishop
d3 and after Bishop a7
I used to I played this position once
again sat in the back row in 2018
roaches leak and I wasn't familiar with
this night and basically I got myself
very very quickly in trouble and to be
honest I'm sort of ashamed to even show
this game because I got the very bad
position but anyway just to show ideas
what exists here for for black and for
white white tries to generally play
through d4 and got to play d4 and black
tries King side attack and the King side
attack is very instructive how black can
employ because after 92 seems like a
natural move to play d4 next black can
play for instance is sort of modern
theory playing I didn't move Knight h7
and the idea is to play h5g for baby
King g7 + f5 as well so by combining
both ideas and again there has been lots
of theory and big topic of discussion
nowadays and I don't want to basically
go into details but in my opinion black
chances are pretty pretty good a Hikaru
Nakamura played it recently as well
three good results so
we should this is one line I there also
pose more to the slow like let's say
rookie one let's say H six but I will
get to more into detail to a four line
little bit later in this game I want to
focus on we should be free in here we
should be free this is the different
line is the old line because effort is
modern trend a four
I decided to play short castle how are
there are more aggressive approaches as
well so that's kind of look at them we
shot a seven this is what actually run
game and number nine in row number nine
and nine per her mark so blow played
against me the same tournament in the
same tournament and I want the game
true but after the opening I didn't
really get much if he but then he made
one mistake I will show what was his
mistake in a second and after this I got
very good position and I managed to win
eventually nice game we should be seven
rookie one I played h6 and this is the
most add a more aggressive approach
basically black tries to avoid castling
a short side and basically prepare a
keep the King on yet and maybe go
alongside sometimes in general prepare
g5 or maybe not age five or in Queen f6
the ninth of four or nine eight seven
Queen f6 nine three five ideas like this
for instance 92 Malkin played nine h5
it's pasta also possible to transpose to
regular lines of short castle which lead
to typical maneuvering play but there
let's let's look at more up grass
approaches princess Knight h7 night 5 my
open but let's look at night eight seven
nine f1 Queen f6 and right now the idea
is 95 d4 seems very reasonable right 93
Bishop takes III also is possible to
play 97 however a bishop legs if he is
very direct gives the power of bishops
true but the idea is that after rook
takes if 397 say D 496 all the Knights
are perfectly played placed Bishop g4 95
comes short Castle I know
big problems for black here if she was
like very playable position white has
pair of bishops but on the other hand
black has good chances to attack on the
on the kingside synergy 500 for those
knives for instance let's move like some
random moves
I know maybe h3 because stop stopping
Bishop g4 rookie in 95 for instance
takes takes something either for comes
up open there's open H file for this
rogue g4 may may be coming as a threat
suddenly what might be my might find
itself in trouble
therefore I think maybe he takes e5 is
possible to try to open the center and
try to create some counter play in the
center / on the Queen side after Detex
if I detective every so maybe 25 in
Queen C 5 is an idea in general pretty
much unbalanced play goes on and both
sides have his own chances this is one
possibility other possibility is much
more aggressive g5 seems like that's why
white black played h6 just to follow up
with g5 and just go for the King side
attack I'd have won g4 92 and this is
what I analyzed a little bit and I
I like that proxy position for both
colors because black plays very
straightforward I need 594 Queen f6
inclusion of g5 e for seems like only
helps by because just creates an effect
but if you play with white you may think
like this g5 d for maneuver I mean like
mark polemarch basically weekend at five
squared so night C for like a sick Queen
f6 Bishop e3 we trade bishops now I will
come to if read the urn I will come to
g3 then square f5 maybe a sort of like
object of wise attack of like White's
play and basically stopping bugs attack
maybe after trading those bishops for
instance
takes Knight takes for instance reunited
for Nyjah for could be possible but I
don't really want to open the G file so
for instance 93 just I'm not sure maybe
I can take on g4 and after h5 95 maybe
ideas could be as well look at 1 & 3
try to open the F file and try to get to
try to make use of this g5 g for
expansion that it simply is a kind of
awakening rather rather than supporting
the supporting Black's attack so there
are some ideas like this
honestly I'm in general in favor of
rather positional approach that's why I
would rather go for something like
castle that's what this is what I did so
let's look at the most classical
approach castle seems like what can be
more natural than this and I really like
this approach and so ever has happened
in my game rocky one where natural was
also possible to play h3 and very often
transposes and if you are playing this
with black I really like the idea that I
am using this game because after all as
a rookie 1 h 6 9 Billy - I played Bishop
e6 and in this position white always has
to decide where Tekken is X or Not Taken
e6 and it's basically another question
of preference in mapping but because
after Bishop takes D 6.86 suddenly this
ro bonafide opens and I think usually
black should have good blood type in
relatively good play on on the kingside
collective 92 or 94 however in this line
it could be particularly good simply
because why waste at Tempe on move here
earlier Bishop c4 Bishop b3
that's why people the theory sort of
shifted towards a for that we don't use
spend time we should be free in case of
Bishop e6 which was immediately
only six and having a four supports
basic wizard expansion and makes blacks
activity less less effective relative to
what could happen in in this position
with Bishop on be free just find this
yeah Bishop Bishop won't be free so we
should be six that's why I don't think
Bishop text Xing is very dangerous for
black
I like black stresses I try the four
comes in in case of before we can just
come back through Bishop back nine f19
age five a four and Queen f6 for
instance and the 994 comes the other
night comes in 97 96 in normal position
in the line from eighth of a for
basically in this position I mean this
position while will be to play but here
we at least managed to throw in another
piece to the attack on the King side
so another thing which is important to
know that in case of rook e8 here Knight
f1 Bishop e6 is not as good anymore
because rook e8 usually has the idea of
basically recapturing the rook on d6 but
after Bishop e6 Bishop takes c6 rook
takes is six is not possible anymore
because d4 and what was on time to play
Knight of one night not from B 1 D 2 F 1
and play d4 right now after text takes
basically Bishop b4 b5 white simply has
big advantage because after takes takes
rook takes d4 366 two pieces in my
opinion are stronger than the rock
versus white can play b3 Bishop b2
Knight a free night Rafi or 893 for
instance and what is clearly better
that's why it's important to know that
rook takes the signal always works it
only this is very typical idea but it
only works if here not rookie one
happens but H 3 H 692 Bishop e6 not not
not Bishop c2 I meant let's say here
after 92 rook e8 for instance rook e1
Bishop e6 and here it works simply
because after Bishop it says we can
simply take a look 286 and d4 is not
possible because I say stands in the way
of the Queen at the supports default
push that's why we have time here to
play rogue a bishop takes a visit rook
takes T 6
how about her happen in my game it was
not possible simply because I mean I
mean could have been possible if I
played rookie denied f1 we should be six
I mean wouldn't be possible irrigate
because simply like his undying played
national of one in the in Casey place
eight starts with H free is not possible
Bishop is six
I played that's why I didn't play rook
capability six immunity because I'm not
really worried about visual exists
except X is six structures in my case my
Lucas is on f8 because if I have to play
beside this this Bishop e6 and take off
the pawn on e6 I certainly don't like my
rock on it Bruce seems pretty silly
difficult air and I'll rather have my
own a way because at some point probably
I would have to anyway play wait I'm
just wasting time piece here so
thank having said that I play be should
be six my opponent played ninth one and
it's important to notice that because
white hasn't played yet h3 white cannot
play here Bishop c2 simply because black
has very aggressive idea here Knight g4
which is also important to know if you
play Italian that if white don't play h3
this idea of 94 is very often possible
and here it works perfectly in here
for instance after Bishop even is
positive this was the same position but
rock was on f1 instead importantly h3
the image of c2 would be possible but in
here is not possible so this is just to
have quick look what will happen if the
points on h3 in this position we can
just pay 85 and this is typical idea we
want to play d5 in with Bishop on c5 in
order to have possibility of retreating
of this Bishop in the future to f8 and
the idea that I use in this game a
little bit more order but anyway it
happened we should be six knight of one
Knight Bishop legs be free I think it's
good to trade those bishops in case of
Knight Bishop c2 as I said earlier
Knight g4 works or is just for example
line broke f1 takes takes 93 Queen e2
when I take C to Ruby one we should
regulate to and black simply wins it's
very instructive my opinion my arm up
and played knight of one and here i
decided to take on be free
Queen takes be free 27 usually it's good
to try those bishops simply because
Bishop won't be free is very annoying
piece if you think about it because it
sort of put some pressure on White's
King is not easy to sometimes there
could be ideas of sacrificing on h6 and
basically some queen g6 check and
something and we can take because we'll
be pinned for instance in here if we can
imagine this bishop comes to h6 pawn
takes on h6 and then Queen comes to g6
basically would be some very strong
attack or of course is very imaginative
future but as an idea this Bishop won't
be free
this Italian Bishop on d3 because Bishop
c4 if I can name it like that it's very
very annoying that's why black wants to
usually trade those bishops and here
this is what I'm doing which it takes be
frequent 8327 and I believe positions
around equal but it's very strategic and
requires us understanding and after 93
rook fe8 h3 I could have played for
instance Bishop a7 but the point is that
I don't really need to play this move
because I want to ideally the perfect
setup here for black is to play d5 and
retreat with this bishop to have faith
because this night on this night
maneuver from deep from B 1 D 2 F 1 g 3
allows sometimes I mean very often
actually this Knight come to f5 were
basically dominates both palms and we
can ever play g6 because politics would
be lost
therefore bishop on f8 for instance
let's say Queen c2 bishop f8 Knight
Rider 5 let's say King h7
maybe Bishop d2 and we can play just g6
this is the entire idea of bringing the
bishop to f8 and basically kicking the
side from a 5 which is usually very
annoying piece to face here so
that's the point that's why I play here
d5 and usually we can play d5 at some
point you should you should do a good
back here
in the Italian so for instance Bishop d2
could have been played as well and here
a black can equalize it can have good
very good game but can easily equalize
after in many ways but the most simple
one is possibly to take take and Queen
e6 try offering to trade Queens is
usually good idea you know in such
positions does it because you are nobody
made that design and Geoffrey comes to
a5 but will don't create any serious
threats and if white doesn't want to
trade Queens that say Queen c2 this
night on g3 I mean this Queen Elsa -
doesn't really do much so we can just
play rook 88 and I don't see real
problems for like the saya the five can
be made very often by with 97 we can
just trade those nice and I don't see
any danger here for black therefore here
my open side to take and basically
change a little bit the nature of the
position because right now pollen d3
becomes sort of a target for me but on
the other hand my pollen e5 is could be
kind of like also a weakness some type
basically may be forced to play f6 at
some point and we can all the guy scores
around or I'm a king which is not a
yellow thing for me I'm a peon so Knight
takes d5 94 and again I if I can I do
bio move this Bishop back to FA that's
what I'm doing
and he in here it's very important to
note that some ideas last bishop like
that h6 don't work yes be sure day after
if takes Queen takes d5 is very nice
of course night of 16 to 7 and xt5 white
just winds upon true pastor Bishop takes
h6 there we don't have to take it's not
checkers we don't have to take on
agencies we can play at first Knight a5
for instance and we are kicking the
screen out from b3 or it doesn't attack
the silent if of 85 anymore let's say
Queen c2 and then we can easily take and
what simply is left with peace down here
because after c4 we can play for
instance f5 or night before hitting the
Queen and c2 why this the back is just
simply winning here being a piece up so
in case of the Bishop matrix doesn't
work them
Marvin play Bishop d2 I played b5 again
Knight Bishop takes h6 never works
because this is 95 idea same thing and
in case of and right now I think
position is still equal but slowly gets
a little bit in blacks favor simply
because I have little bit more space and
usually when whenever white decides to
take on d5 it's very committal decision
simply because in the long run
black will have this pawn on e5 versus
this D free pawn and usually if you are
having sub structure the side of the
pawn on e5 or let's say if with the
mirror-image pawn on e4 and pawn g6
we preparing with white for instance it
usually is in the favor of the side that
has more advanced pointing here I have
this more advanced pond so I have a
little more space Pond III is rather
good rock would would be a sort of
object of my attack my pony five rather
is strength rather than a weakness here
in my opinion so after Bishop evade
Bishop d2 my vampire I play b5 and here
I mean bottom plate move a for pretty
quickly if I remember correctly but it's
already a mistake here basically was the
it was time there was it was time
basically to admit the position is just
equal and play rock 81 play solid bring
the last piece to the center and make
sure only three this week week pawn is
secured maybe at some point prepared d4
don't avoid simplifications and if
necessary agree to a draw this was
correct back out play princess Queen e6
I don't think I'm any better here my
position is any better Brooke 88
possibly I would go next maybe 95 c5 I
would try maybe to win somehow but with
correct play definitely what has no real
weaknesses defeats only potential
weakness that I can really get into
right now and if white decides to play
d4 it will be basically made central
fight wear a white shouldn't be any
worse therefore my after this was the
correct paper my 1 by F 4 and here this
is actually helping black and this is a
very important idea to know because
after before suddenly black is just
better I continue gaining space and
usually I agree that this a 4 before
gives text the
I mean certified for this Foursquare for
pieces that say Queen or night but in
here more important is a different thing
that this night from f3 or the or e4
cannot really get to see for it's not
easy because this is among the only two
stands the way and neither is already
developed to e4 is not easy and there
are bigger issues for instance Poland
III that's potentially weak and opening
B file is rather in blacks favor simply
because the screen will be under some
pressure on to be on the B file so
having said that my open plate here a
five objectively I feel red bag is
slightly better here I play look a bit
very logical a5 is could be again
another not the best move
simply because after a five and rugby a
b8 I have this be five square for my
room very often and this is actually
what happened in the game because after
a five k b8 we see four I play rugby
five and suddenly pollen fi is a
weakness and I'm hitting on this pawn is
very hard to defend it and I think
already black is just clearly better not
even study bar but maybe between
slightly better and much better out out
I would say definitely I'm having the
initiative I'm in charge in case of
Queen a4 I could play for instance it'll
be five or maybe look 88 rookie d8 and
if Queen c2 Africans are playing B 3
will be 1 and the five basically is
trying to kick all black speed white
pieces back and after 93 just Bishop d6
and it's clear that Pony five remains
the weakness my pieces are better placed
therefore d4 is never an option because
I just whip go F or C for weekends all
the squares I can simply prepare a
further expansion of my pawns
like is simply simply better here okay
if because right now is already black
who is better let's actually switch
let's flip the board and look at it
posits disposition from blacks
perspective because I think I employed a
very nice strategy in this game here my
opponent okay first of all people is
Christopher but if see for neither for
takes takes is clearly better for from
black because d4 is not possible because
the point just fall it's also important
to note that this whenever we can we
should play actively and bring this in
here we should play 94 simply because it
just throws another piece to the to
build whites camp and create some
problems and we are not afraid of this
because d4 is the man option as I said
so here my plan play Quincy for possibly
instead of a 5 you have tonight g3 but
after Leucadia drew KD 1 a 5 Quincy - he
sort of forced to long-term defense for
instance I have six on the frieze
hanging possibly Bishop III he still
hold somehow relative balance but
definitely if I have to choose I'll
definitely choose black here but
probably it was much better because
after a5 was what he did with bona fide
simply a weakness it's very committed
move and you when you play why do you
have to always make sure that a 5 is not
is actually good that it doesn't become
a weakness
rook ab8 Quincy for rugby 5 very strong
move but on this move I fought for quite
a bit
simply because I realized that he
basically needs to come up with some
direct idea to solve his opening
problems
I mean minerally despondently free and I
wasn't sure if Brooke b5 actually allows
him
to break free we've moved like d4 and so
what I was mostly calculating but
eventually I came to realization that it
d4 doesn't really work
therefore after d4 I played a five
i multiplied of files were calculated 93
II for and right now a 95 is impossible
because takes takes rook and takes takes
Andrew takes d5 I'm simply pull up there
is no any compensation for this pawn and
after knowledge for night xa5 Queen e2
Knight b6 is very important move that
were basically I'm taking the C 4 square
under control and with my rock because
when I'd cover C 4 square and rock on
the fifth leg covers f5 pawn and I
basically am just winning here because
I'm pawn up and all those who worldwide
pieces are misplaced and my perfect
place actually perfectly and yeah it is
basically came over here he played on g3
B takes c3 B takes c3 Knight X E and now
an ITEX of a 5 would have been a big big
mistake because or suddenly after Queen
82 all my pieces are sort of loose in
the only 5th rank 9 only 5 a ruby 5 fall
under c4 and as rookin b5 defends I
don't know I've not only if I was as
well lose because after c4 a bishop from
the two would hit on design on line 5
therefore I wouldn't have anything
better than just simply coming back
hoping that after c4 f 9 before but
after Puente is a six position just
roughly equal simply you know I'm not
even born up here and we basically
traded a 5.4 a6 which were pawn on e5
simply a weakness and pulmonary six
gives me very important be 5 square for
my book
same thing would have happened after
this Queen Texas explosion just equal
therefore I hear I was very happy to
find 96 simply because I haven't played
Knight f6 I threatened to take on a five
right now overnight and my rook on night
and if I broken b5 after Queen e2 will
not be hanging and also I open my queen
- look at this pawn on d4 suddenly Black
has two weaknesses what what has two
weaknesses that they have to look after
and suddenly is not easy it's not easy I
think already Black is much better and
all start with this move e5 which of the
mistake in my opinion and here my
opponent finally made tactical blunder
and after which I gained like decisive
advantage probably was the best just to
come back admit that there is nothing
better than this
but after takes takes rook d8 for
instance black is clearly better
rukon I mean you keep hitting on
postponed e3 and still threatening to
take on a5 there it's simply just
overwhelming in my opinion also another
remove possible is f5 and King h7 which
is the similar positions because
whenever the happened before happens I
can play if or pollen if I was a gain
weakness there are lots of ideas for
black were or everywhere basically I'm
much better therefore he played rook eb1
but anyway this was the best that's the
best play he played rook e1 Ruby Ruby
one basically hoping for that income in
complications in technical complications
he may have to come swindle out but
basically I calculated
nicely that after night XA 5 Queen I - I
can just take the other pawn and I
basically collect two weaknesses and
actually my after my daugther a5 is
already hanging after rook takes d5 8x b
5 because after a takes pinned xa5
before both pieces are cannot defend
themselves
and two I would be just pong at least
upon at least upon up but such an
important point and also what backwards
position is collapsing response if ruby
week and most importantly king oMG one
would be also in danger so let's see
what happened
ninety-four Quinta XD to 98th one and
now I played first remove 23 simply
after Quinn text b5 I were to take have
an idea of quintic c3 if Knight takes d5
rocky 5 does the best the point
therefore I force him to take on c7 if
he wants to he wants to be only pawn up
on down order to pose down but this is
met by before which undermines this
knight on d4 which suddenly it's very
unstable because if I take on c3
seems like it's also be two pawns up and
[Music]
game gubec just came over there for my
open play rook c1 trying to hold on to
the c3 pawn and I was before but this
falls into another tactical idea which
is very again very nice and II applied
III F takes G free rope takes c3 Knight
c6 and yet the idea here that after
takes I can take and let's say King H to
King quintic c1 just wins the entire
piece and we need the game the
rubenstein is under attack right now
and he playing at 6 trying to maybe
complicate things and but anyway
positions just lost 4 for white because
after be free
Queen B 8 trying to pin me on the back
rank and Akkadian peace be to bleep be
free pond I just played
b2 and this here are calculated after
Queen text bit rocky - I'm simply
winning simply winning because of the
attack that I have on his King as well
and
he's very very poor position of his
pieces for incest Queen b7 Queenie for
here he resigned by the way because
after Queen b7 Queenie 4 for instance I
can just either take on g2 or basically
after 97 I can just be a piece up so
that this here he resigned as far as I
was Rivera happy with this game and I I
think in this game there were lots of
ideas were basically strategic ideas
that are important to know for instance
this point a5 is very responsible and
very committal move that sometimes may
backfire at you you have to be careful
booth playing such moves also it's good
to play sometimes move like before if
you are gaining space and you have to
have to worry about weaken in this
Foursquare another thing which was I
think very important is the idea of
playing d5 and actually rhetoric the
bishop to a fight to prevent all the
kind of counter play on the Kings side
and finally
the trading heared of the bishops going
like backwards a little bit like
training the bishops is usually in
blacks favor because it simplifies the
position white is usually I mean as
white begins the game why duty is in
charge so training some pieces usually
helps reduce the tension and helps with
the defense
so Bishop e6 is a good idea offensive
idea not fearing here this structures
because very with the rukon of eight and
having idea in my nine inch five and a
four or maybe ninety seven ninety six
maybe Queen have six Queen disease or
Queen yet Queen g6
maybe doubling the row gonna f file
white black has pretty good play on the
other hand is important also to note
that white can play here a form of which
is in my opinion a little bit better and
that's why the theory shifted towards
this move and why let's quickly have a a
lot maybe I'm not sure whether there is
enough time for the second game but I
will just quickly show what happens in
my what happened in my game versus Rena
and remember if it was the same
tournament and I played a four in the
same position a four shot Castle rookie
one and after age six eight three rook
e8 here again
he decided play rook e8 but here he has
clear I mean a clear clear idea in mind
to play Bishop e6 as I said earlier he
can do it yet but the thing is that it's
very hard for me to come where move the
knight BD to it's them by far the most
logical move and I think the majority of
players go for it
night Billy to Bishop e6 and after takes
he can just take the rook other idea is
possible of course as I said earlier to
play Bishop e6 immunity and I think
Vladimir Kramnik
played it very very frequently if I'm
not mistaking played against Daniel
in Qatar 2014 15 2015 if I'm not
mistaken I'm not sure but I think I'm
not even mistaken and basically it was
very unbalanced game after takes takes
but here because we black heaven white
hasn't committed yet to develop inside
to d2 it's possible to play Bishop III
or maybe play before and Bishop a7
Bishop e3 and then try to train those
bishops and then play an IBD - and just
in one move don't have to waste time for
91 and then Knight X III just keep this
big night on d2 and then prepare my beta
for at some point and this is what Y
should generally do in such positions
maybe also explain expand with b5 at
some point this will white should do and
in case of 9h 594 it's okay to page if
free for instance it's as an idea it's
important to know that with white some
this is the sort of approach to approach
this position of course at least very
unbalanced play which requires analysis
for instance let's move let's make some
fearsome or some random moves Ruby fruit
that's a 97 9 b d2
as a queen e8 for instance maybe not
Queen yet because Queen it already
allows d4
it's already after takes takes what
study better because of the center
however in here at Sinai d6 d4 takes
takes here's the center true but we can
play me behind h5 out of 4 and we can
play for instance g3 here and I don't
see anything wrong with this positions
pretty much on balance still however I
prefer white in this case other a
possible idea is to basically not take
on the foreign player moves like 97 and
basically then try to play in either for
Queen f6 something like this but then
for instance Geoffrey could be possible
and position under are very very
playable long games and basically
I'm not it's under debate theoretical
debate who is better here was probably
producer around equal therefore having
said that map and South Africa's rocky
energy to be shall be six here we can
take of the rock coming relative to the
position without on I don't know and I 1
will be 1 but here takes takes before
Bishop a7 Queen c2 is the sort of the
main line in here and Marvin play 27
again please note that I played before
trying to kick his Bishop to a 7 in case
I played for instance 9f one maybe that
if I would have fall and after before he
might have come back to f8 which is
usually a desirable place for the square
for them for the Bishop never before is
typical we should pay 714 is Bishop to
go back Queen c2 Queen d7 9 f 1 and d5
and here basically other possibility is
97 there are lots of ideas for instance
very interesting ideas also 97 night of
196 93 and this also leads to unbalance
play I think why it should be started by
BA however I played myself one one time
disposition of white and I lost so you
know anything and anything can happen
after 27 night of 21 he open play d5
trying to break free in the mid the
center immediately 9 3 3 is I played 93
it actually already is not the best move
because after I was supposed to play
Bishop III takes takes and try to trade
those bishops because us as I said
earlier
white trade black wants to trade those
bishops on c4 light square Bishop Slyke
here for instance and usually I made not
usually but sometimes this Bishop on c5
can become also a problem for for white
therefore it's important to note like I
did I could have done in the game I
didn't but I could have done
should help them probably or here we
should be free this Bishop on the asylum
basically puts lots of pressure on f2
that's why we should just trade this
Bishop of Bishop III same thing here
coming sorry I'm shift like switching
the lines and so I'm just want to shout
an idea ideas that I have in mind but
for Queen d7 here d5 the correct move is
the game Bishop e3 is the same tip same
idea that black did earlier with Bishop
e6 takes takes rook takes c6 which piece
of -7 is annoying and the bishop on c1
doesn't have any real future on it
deserves wise pieces as well it should
be traded and again theory goes on which
plays the frenetic Seyfried let's say
room d8 be filed it's my analysis 97 and
c4 are some ideas like this after d4 95
night for incest 96 positions pretty
much unclear both sides have its own
chances if in K in for instance black
and maybe Tigers non-stop 105 and play
rook F 694 or maybe rotated free maybe
play also brought back my pipe c6 and
probability of 0 to 36 on the other hand
white can play some random moves like g3
try to cover a foreign King G to make
sure that my f4 never happens also King
h2 is possible preparing on all of this
there are four positions full of
strategical ideas and needs further
basically you know exploration having
said that I played Knight G 3 which is
not the best move but I decided to play
it I followed that one to keep more
pieces on the board rook da
Bishop b2 and I my ideas to play here c4
at some point and the Ruby shouldn't be
too it seems like I'm stupidly pulling
this bishop in front of the policy free
but ideas to play c4 and then I covered
the Foursquare so I didn't want to trade
was before how to play want to play
against this Bishop on beat 2 on i7 and
actually kind of worked for me in this
game because after b5 it's not only
moved positions roughly equal it's
possible also to take take a queen d3
and this position is also playable
possibly after takes the king of one
white can hope for something however
positions
around equals still and after b5 Queen
b3 detects 40 takes d4 rook takes rook
d68 XB v 8x b 595 rugby free
maybe i skip through the last few moves
but it maybe i should have said that
that here is the important idea
basically to take take route e6 and
rubbed it free because everything is in
the center for black and black can take
control over the d file it's possible
however it runs into other thing which
happen in the game because takes takes
neither v route d3 and right now I've
beautiful tactical idea Luke takes a
seven and if Knight takes a seven-night
XD 5 and that's basically what I'm
talking about I play against this Bishop
on a seven so you can also try to play
against this Bishop on a seven it
usually it not always work in my this
game it worked but you can you don't
have to try always these bishops it all
depends on personal preferences and what
do you think is the best just but in
general you should remember that such
ideas exist here after rotates f4 f f3 I
took Knight X a7 and c4 suddenly my
bishop opens up points only five
attacked and I think I have decent
pressure here
my opponent went wrong here and after 96
he who could have equalized but he
played Queen d2 and I had some chances
to win this game and unfortunately I did
not win this game it was draw let me
quickly show how it happened Quincy free
B takes c4 Quinn takes D to rock tasty
to Bishop takes e5 and after in him here
I thought I very good chances to win
this game because I'm hitting on one OC
seven-night on f5 is very powerful
because put some pressure on the hd7 h6
and f6 and
this bishop hits here and here I thought
I have very good chances also rocks one
could be coming to attack this guy but
tactically it all perfectly works for
black there are basically two ways that
black can basically hold this there is
night h5 which is very instructive
ignoring policy seven ignoring
everything simply getting out of this my
bishop legs of SIG's idea and after
let's say ninety seven King gave at
night I mean Luke a1 simply entering
some endgame and positions basically
roughly equal it's a ruby seven analyst
bouquet five group D one King G to group
B one basically what has black his nut
counter played here to make a draw for
instance takes 9 g5 and all the rook
angles will be drawn and if neither for
counts I would be forced to enter the
rook endgame therefore after b5 for
instance it is just the drive though
upon up there is no way I can win this
with with white other with movies what
he played in the game knight c6 and here
also I thought I had pretty good chance
during the game but I actually I didn't
I thought that age six was the best try
and yes he was a bus driver
anyway black holes after for instance
takes text and 94 and I want to go dive
in too deep into analysis but black
holes for instance we should take before
rook takes d4 King f1 and again rook and
games are very likely to be drawn and
after f5 my bone structure is very
likely getting messed up because I can't
bring my King here if I could bring my
king to e2 and basically play rook c1
and kinky free then yes
I would be winning but after a 5 I can't
really do it because after King it -
there is possible to take on e4 also is
possible to make the f4f ridin relaxed
so much but taking on e4 will seem
sufficient I can give freedom different
for instance just to quickly show takes
takes kinky freaky free seems like it
should be just draw
and after taking on a 5c3 Brooksie one a
Roxy for this looks again like a draw I
don't believe it - do I have any chances
to win this so let's finally see happen
with her what happened the game because
neither she was anyway the best try
because he would have to find basic 94
but I decided to play Bishop the xf6
hoping that hereafter Roxy one human
find 94 because if he doesn't play 94 I
think I'm I had three good chances for
instance after 95 I gotta f4 maybe and
otherwise ignite X before root X T for
rival 5 remains very strong and I can
take it on c7 basically creates a mating
Nets making attack could be very
unpleasant but 94 is very strong and
this transfers into draw her grand game
after up next e4 Knight takes pawn takes
and this we played for another 25 moves
which after which if we eventually agree
to a draw
it doesn't really matter rest of the
game so here I'm gonna stop anyway I
think it was I mean in this lecture
tried to show just to sum up I tried to
show different ideas for both colors in
Italian game this opening leads to very
balanced strategic fight were both sigh
have its own chances and I encourage
everyone to learning on his or her own
details about this opening clicking
games of grandmasters and I hope is
interested someone to go for this
opening so thank you guys for for this
in this lecture and see you next time
[Music]
you